still act prudently in connection with
the facts now some of the facts have
been disturbing some of the facts have
been ugly but those are the facts and
that's that's my job is to present the
facts as facts if I have an editorial
comment on the facts I give it to you
but I want you to know that's my
editorial comment versus what data or
science will say also our Muslim
brothers and sisters begin the
observation of Ramadan for this evening
and we wish them all the best the
hospitalization rate is down again
so that is good news the overall if you
project the curve everybody's looking at
curves nowadays if you look at the curve
the curve continues to go down and
that's also in the total hospitalization
number bounces up and down a little bit
but it's clearly down number of
intubations bounces a little bit but
it's also clearly down the number of new
covert cases walking in the door or
being diagnosed is relatively flat that
is not great news we'd like to see that
going down but it's not going up either
the number of lives lost is still
breathtakingly tragic 438 that number is
not coming down as fast as we would like
to see that number come down and what
we're looking at at this point is okay
we're on the down side of the of the
curve the numbers are trending down do
they continue to trend down
so do they pop back up if they continue
to trend down how fast is the decline
and how low will the decline go in other
words if 1300 people or about that
number keep walking in the door then
you're going to have a
as a proportionate with the number of
people walking in the door so we want to
see the number of people walking in the
door reduced the number of new
infections reduced so we hit a low
plateau if you will but we don't know
what that is and we don't know when it
is and if you look at the number of
incoming cases it's been remarkably flat
for the past several days so that's the
best indicator of how containment is
working and how the closed-down policies
are working and over the past few days
we basically flattened at 1,300 new
cases a day which is not great we'd like
to see those new cases reducing even
more and we'd like to see them reducing
faster you then have other long-term
questions is there a second way of the
virus we talk about the 1918 pandemic it
came in three waves is there a second
wave does the virus mutate and come back
the federal officials are starting to
talk about the fall and potential issues
in the fall they're worried about the
virus waning somewhat during the summer
remember those talk will it go away when
the weather gets warm no one's really
saying it will go away when the weather
gets warm in the summer but there's
still a theory that the virus could slow
during the summer but then come back in
the fall if it comes back in the fall
then it comes back with a normal flu
season that's then problematic because
you're then quote-unquote testing for
the flu and you're testing for kovat on
top of all the other tests you do that
could be a possible overwhelming of the
testing system if people could have the
flu
or could have Co vyd in the fall and
they don't know which it is they could
get nervous and start going into the
healthcare system which could then bring
back a capacity issue in the healthcare
system
so that's something we have to worry
about and watch nursing homes they are
our top priority they have been from day
one remember how the nursing home system
works they are private facilities they
get paid to provide a service they get
regulated by the state government there
are certain rules and regulations that
they must follow and we put in
additional rules and regulations on
nursing homes in the midst of this
crisis staff must have appropriate PPE
they must have their temperatures
checked before they come into the
facility there are no visitors
who are coming into the facility which
is a tremendous hardship but it's
necessary to protect public health if
they have a co vid positive person in
the facility that person has to be in
quarantine they have to have separate
staff for the co vid residents versus
the non kovat residents if they can't
care for the person in the facility they
have to transfer the person to another
facility the nursing home is responsible
for providing appropriate care if they
cannot provide that care then they have
to transfer the person to another
facility
they have to notify residents and family
members within 24 hours if any resident
has positive for Kovac or if any
resident suffers a copepod related death
that is a regulated regulation that they
have to follow and they have to readmit
kovat positive residence but only if
they have the ability to provide the
adequate level of care on the Department
of Health and CDC guidelines if they do
not have the ability to provide the
appropriate level of care then they have
to transfer that patient or they call
the Department of Health and the
Department of Health will transfer that
patient right but that is how the
relationship works the state has very
guidelines on privately run facilities
they get paid to take care of a resident
that resident that patient must have a
state directed level of care if they
cannot provide that they can't have the
resident in their facility period those
are the rules
we're going to undertake an
investigation of nursing homes now to
make sure they're following the rules
it's going to be a joint Department of
Health and attorney general
investigation but those are the rules
they get paid to take care of a resident
and they have to do do it in hortence
with state rules and if they don't we
will take appropriate action and the
State Department of Health and the
Attorney General are going to be
commencing an investigation to make sure
all those policies are in place and
being followed
if they're not being followed they can
be subjected to a fine or they can lose
their license it's that simple
testing testing is going to be a major
operation that happens from now until
this situation is over it's new it's
technical it's complex
it's a political football but testing
does a number of things for us
number one it reduces the spread of the
virus by finding people who are positive
tracing their contacts and isolating
them that's a function of testing
testing also what they call antibody
testing you test people to find out if
they have the antibodies why because if
they have the antibodies they can donate
blood for convalescent plasma which is
one of the therapeutic treatments so you
want to find people who had it so you
can identify them to donate for
convalescent plasma the testing also can
tell you the infection rate in
the population where it's higher where
it's lower to inform you on a reopening
strategy and then when you start
reopening you can watch that infection
rate to see if it's going up and if it's
going up slow down on the reopening
strategy okay so there are different
forms of testing for different purposes
all of them are important it was vital
for any state I believe to first get a
baseline study of where you are on the
infection rate all we know to date is
the hospitalization rate how many people
coming into hospitals that is all we
have been tracking that's all we know
and then from that you've had also surve
anecdotal extrapolations on the
hospitalization rate saying I think the
infection rate is this I think the
infection rate is that I said I want to
have the infection rate so we have
undertaken the largest most
comprehensive study of New York State to
find out what is the infection rate and
that we started a few days ago sample
size so far 3,000 people statewide let's
find out what the infection rate is we
have preliminary data on phase 1 and
this is going to be ongoing we did about
the 3,000 tests we're going to continue
this testing on a rolling basis we'll
have a larger and larger sample but I
want to see snapshots of what is
happening with that rate is it going up
is it flat is it going down and it can
really give us data to make decisions we
did 3000 surveys in about 19 counties 40
localities across the state the surveys
will collected at grocery stores box
stores etc and that's important it means
you're testing people who
definition are out of the home and not
at work okay
what does that mean I don't know but
that has to be a factor that's taken
into consideration these are people who
were out and about shopping they were
not people who were in their home they
are not people who were isolated they're
not people who were quarantined who you
could argue probably had a lower rate of
infection because they wouldn't come out
of the house these are people who were
outside these are people who were not at
work so they're probably not essential
workers okay so that has to be
calibrated but what we found so far as
the statewide number is thirteen point
nine percent tested positive for having
the antibodies what does that mean it
means these are people who were infected
and who developed the antibodies to
fight the infection so they had the they
were infected three weeks ago right four
weeks ago five weeks ago six weeks ago
but they had the virus they developed
the antibodies and they are now
quote-unquote recovered 13.9% just about
14% breakdown male female female twelve
percent positive males close to 16
percent fifteen point nine percent
positive regionally Long Island at
sixteen point seven New York City of
twenty one point two was just a Rockland
eleven point seven and rest of state
three point six this basically
quantifies what we've been seeing
anecdotally and what we have known but
it puts numbers to it rest of the state
is basically upstate New York three
point six it was have been about seventy
percent of the cases that we've had in
the state was just a Rockland we had an
initial
significant problem remember Westchester
had the largest hottest cluster in the
country at one time eleven percent so
it's literally somewhere in between New
York City 21 which again supports what
we knew and it's totally Long Island
16.7 so it's not that far behind New
York City and it is significantly worse
than Westchester Rockland we've been
talking about Westchester Rockland and
Nassau Suffolk basically is one but
there is a variation with the Long
Island numbers by race
Asians about eleven point seven percent
african-american 22 percent Latino
Hispanic 22 percent multi none other 22
percent white nine point one percent
this reflects more the regional
breakdown african-american and Latinos
are in this survey disproportionately
from New York City and New York City is
at 21 percent so the african-american
number Latino numbers 22 percent but and
the Upstate whites they're talking about
more upstate which is nine but it's
three point six in the survey by age
nothing extraordinary here we did not
survey anyone under 18 so it starts with
18 years old 18 to 24 8% 45 to 54 16 75
plus 13 but it's a small percent of the
total again how many 75 year olds were
out shopping and about that is the group
that's supposed to be isolating because
they are the most of all in the world 65
to 74 also but that's the distribution
the again the sample was by definition
people who were outside the home so we
have to analyze that
what does that do to the numbers but
that is a factor that has to be taken
into consideration the if the infection
rate is thirteen point nine percent then
it changes the theories of what the
death rate is if you get infected
thirteen percent of the population is
about 2.7 million people who have been
infected if you look at what we have now
as a death total which is fifteen
thousand five hundred that would be
about 0.5% death rate but two big
caveats first its preliminary
preliminary data it's only three
thousand well three thousand is a
significant data set but it's it's still
preliminary and when we say there are
fifteen thousand five hundred deaths
that number is going to go up those
deaths are only hospitalization or
nursing home deaths that does not have
what are called at home deaths right
this is doesn't include people who died
in their home and we're not in a
hospital or a nursing home we still have
to compile all that data and then the at
home deaths you have to go back and try
to find out what was the cause of death
for those at home deaths but and then
add them to the number of deaths
connected to kovat it gets even more
complicated
because in California they're now
finding deaths that go back to last
December or January that they believe
work Ovid related and people didn't even
know about kovat at that time so if you
then go back to December in January and
start to look at the number of deaths
and check them for a copepod related
death I don't even know how you do that
practically you'll see that total
number of of deaths go go up but that
15,500 is not an accurate total number
of deaths in my opinion well in fact
it's not an accurate total number of
deaths because it does not count in home
deaths at home deaths it's not accurate
because there will have been many other
deaths that were never tested for
covered that should be attributed to
that number but with those caveats
that's what we see in this survey it
also supports the decision that we
talked about to have a regional analysis
and decision making upstate New York is
3.6% New York City is 21% what you do in
a place with 21% is not the same thing
necessarily that you would do in a place
with 3.6 percent it's just not it's the
same theory that some states open now
and New York doesn't because the facts
should dictate the action and if the
facts dictate the action when you have
different facts excuse me you have
different action so when we talk about a
regional analysis on reopening that's
exactly right because look at the facts
in that area sorry but there's a second
complicating factor because the rows is
what you do in a region still has to be
coordinated because you have a pent up
demand in the whole tri-state area where
one region opens up for business you
could see people come in from literally
from the tri-state area and overwhelm
that that region we try to rationalize
with Connecticut in New Jersey because
there have been facilities in
Connecticut that were open and you have
all sorts of New York license plates
there so yes regional analysis but
understand on that
analysis that you still exist in a
tri-state area with millions of people
who are looking for something to do to
get out of the house and put the kids in
the car and go so that has to be
factored in because that is a
significant factor we also have to do
more to get testing in the
african-american and Latino communities
we talked about health disparities this
state did not have the kind of
disparities we've seen in other states
but I want to understand them and I want
to address them they're going to be a
number of factors while you could have a
higher percentage of positives in the
african-american Latino community there
were existing health disparities there
were existing comorbidities underlying
illnesses diabetes etc I also believe
you have a greater percentage of the
quote-unquote essential workers who are
african-american Latino and while
everyone else or many other people had
the opportunity to lock down at home as
terrible as that was the essential
workers had to get up every morning and
go out and drive the bus and drive the
train and deliver the food and do all
those essential services that allowed
people to stay at home
also you have more people in the New
York City area more people getting on
subways getting on buses more people
dealing with that density and we know
that's where it communicates but New
York City Housing Authority we're
starting more testing today at New York
City Housing Authority facilities you
talked about public housing I was a HUD
secretary I worked in public housing all
across this nation that is some of the
densest housing in the United States of
America people crammed into elevators
crammed through small lobbies
overcrowding in their apartment so
public housing does pose a special issue
and it should be addressed
I also want to get more testing in
african-american and Latino communities
all through the New York City area
including Long Island after this I want
to work with congressman Hakeem Jeffries
and Congress member of Ed Clark and
Congress member Nydia Velazquez to help
us work with the churches in those
communities the churches have
volunteered many of them to be testing
sites one of the problems is finding a
testing site but many churches have said
they would be willing to use their
facilities for testing sites as we ramp
up the testing I want to get it into the
african-american and Latino community
and using the churches as a network I
think is going to be extraordinarily
effective but this is something that New
York should lead the way on answering
this question and addressing this issue
also want to speak to a point from our
friends in Washington
Senator McConnell who is the head of the
Senate you know we've been talking about
funding for state and local governments
and it was not in the bill that the
house is going to pass today they said
don't worry don't worry don't worry the
next bill as soon as the Senate passed
it this current bill senator Mitch
McConnell goes out and he says maybe the
states should declare bankruptcy
okay this is one of the really dumb
ideas of all time and you know I said to
my colleagues in Washington I would have
insisted that state and local funding
was in this current bill because I don't
believe they want to fund state and
local governments and not the fun state
and local governments is incredibly
short-sighted they want to fund small
business fund the airlines I understand
that
but state and local government funds
police and fire and teachers and schools
how do you not fund police and fire and
teachers
and schools in the midst of this crisis
yes airlines are important yes more
business is important so police and fire
and health care workers who are the
frontline workers and when you don't
fund the state then the state can't fund
that those services makes no sense to me
also makes no sense that the entire
nation is dependent on what the
governor's do to reopen we've
established that it's up to this
governor it's up to this governor it's
up to this governor but then you're not
going to fund the state government what
do you think I'm gonna do it alone how
do you think this is gonna work and then
to suggest we're concerned about the
economy states should declare bankruptcy
that's how you're gonna bring this
national economy back by States
declaring bankruptcy you want to see
that market fall through the cellar
like New York state declare bankruptcy
let Michigan declare bankruptcy let
Illinois declare bankruptcy let you
California declare bankruptcy you will
see a collapse of this national economy
so just daun vicious is saying when
Senator McConnell said this is a blue
state bailout what he's saying is if you
look at the states that have coronavirus
problems they tend to be democratic
states New York California Michigan
Illinois they are democratic states so
if you fund states that are suffering
from the coronavirus they're democratic
states don't help new york state because
it is a democratic state how ugly a
thought I mean just think of just think
of what he's saying
people died 15,000 people died in New
York but they were predominantly
Democrats so why should we help them
I mean for crying out loud if there was
ever a time you're gonna put aside for
you to put aside your pettiness and your
partisanship and this political lens
that you see the world through Democrat
and Republican and we help Republicans
but we don't help Democrats that's not
who we are it's just not who we are as a
people I mean if there's ever a time for
humanity and decency now is the time and
if there was ever a time to stop your
political obsessive political bias and
anger which is what it's morphed into
just a political anger now is the time
and you want to politically divide this
nation now with all that's going on how
irresponsible and how reckless I'm the
governor all New Yorkers
Democrat Republican independent I don't
even care what your political party is I
represent you and we are all there to
support each other this is not the time
or the place or the situation to start
your divisive politics it is just not
and that's why look our rules been very
simple from day one there is no red in
blue they should have never been a red
and blue when it comes to any important
issue but certainly not now
and that's not what this country is all
about it's not red and blue it's red
white and blue and when we talk about
New York tough were all New York tough
Democrats and Republicans and we're all
smart and we're all disciplined and
we're all unified and we're all in this
together and we understand that and
that's how we operate and we operate
with love and we're strong enough to say
love to say love is not a weakness it is
a strength and New Yorkers are that
strong questions governor we're seeing
over 1100
correction staffers and inmates who
tested positive for Kovac what more can
the state do to to release people
detained on parole violations more
quickly and what about releasing utterly
elderly a medic medically vulnerable
people and making sure that inmates are
getting hand sanitizer is there any
ability to get the national authorities
to our jails so as of today there's 263
prisoners who have tested positive for
kovat and then from that we are
quarantine people there's 1397 people in
the prison system which have been
quarantined we actually have not seen
the kind of outbreaks that we feared
that we would see we're monitoring it
very closely we've done a number of
things including stopping visitation and
doing isolation above and beyond
but within humanity making sure that
you're not putting people solitary
confinement
so we're monitoring this very closely
we're getting briefed on it every
morning we've already taken a number of
steps the technical parole violations
that people over 55 with the 90 days and
as the situation evolves and warrants
changes will change my self-proclaimed
Grim Reaper Senator McConnell for
another second he represents the state
of Kentucky ok when it comes to fairness
New York state puts much more money into
the federal pot than it takes out ok at
the end of the year we put in to that
federal pot one hundred and sixteen
billion dollars more than we take out ok
his state the state of Kentucky takes
out a hundred and forty eight billion
more than they put in okay so he's a
federal legislature he's distributing
the federal pot of money
New York puts in more money to the
federal pot than it takes out his state
takes out more than it puts it
Senator McConnell who's getting bailed
out here
it's your state that is living on the
money that we generate your state is
getting bailed out not my state about
the National Guard I didn't get an
answer on that I was wondering if
there's any thoughts on he's in the
National Guard to clean jails and
prisons or even nursing homes not at
this time okay enough tests are not
available anywhere we need more tests
for prisons more tests for nursing homes
more tests of antibodies we need more
tests across the board that is not just
New York that is nationwide that's why
everyone is scrambling on this testing
testing testing and how do you bring it
up to scale Jesse we are testing in
prisons the same way that we're testing
outside of prison so people who are
demonstrating the symptoms that are
associated with it that we know of come
into direct contact and so they're
getting the same standard it's being
applied within prison walls as is to
everybody else if they fall under those
conditions yes have you called Senator
McConnell have you made any contact with
him do you intend to no on the issue of
the 20% of New York City residents who
seem to be testing positive via the
antibody testing does this change the
calculation these abhi contact tracing I
mean that's two million people basically
in New York City that could conceivably
have been exposed no it doesn't change
the calculus a little contact tracing is
not the answer it's not the be-all and
end-all but it's one of the tools and in
a very small toolbox right you don't
have that many effective tools to use so
it's a tool in a small toolbox and
you're right the tone of the question is
right could you ever test every test and
trace every positive no
the state Department of Health is
charged with regulating nursing homes
and investigating claims of neglect and
making sure they're complying with
regulations why is it that they haven't
done that already if that's what their
job no they do do it they do it on an
ongoing basis this is a crisis situation
for nursing homes they are under a lot
of pressure we understand that through
no fault of their own by the way this
happens to be a virus that happens to
attack elderly people and nursing homes
are the place of elderly people so they
this is a very intense situation for
nursing homes we get it but they still
have to perform their job and do their
job by the rules and regulations it's
you know what went wrong in hospitals
what went wrong in society what went
wrong nothing mother nature brought a
virus and the virus attacks young people
I'm sorry old people and nothing went
wrong
nobody's to blame but for creation of
the situation but they have to deal with
the situation governor the situation at
the Rochester City Schools apparently is
becoming increasingly critical the
school superintendent there is suggested
he's gonna leave at the end of June and
their finances teetering as they were
even before all of us have gotten
increasingly dire is there a concern
that you have there and is there
anything that the state can do at this
point
we've been talking about the Rochester
School District for a few months I don't
think anything has happened recently Rob
do you know in the budget we did give
them some flexibility and gave them
advance payments on their situation
I think the superintendent there had
some desire to make some reductions but
dealing with locally with the board on
what they needed to do we gave them some
flexibility and we gave them advance
payments to the tune of close to thirty
million dollars in this budget so that
they could use those tools but like
every other district they're gonna have
problems but they were actually treated
and we're giving
flexibility than any other district in
the state what should these facilities
have done differently when this guidance
came out from do H saying that they had
to either admit or admit new patients to
these homes and one day voices concerns
saying hey we don't have enough PPE they
don't have enough space our staffs
calling out sick
what's that communication like this toh
and house do H been handling yeah they
should have followed the rules and the
rule says if you can't provide adequate
care to a patient you must transfer the
patient period yes and then if they
can't transfer a patient to another
facility so they call other facilities
do you have a bed available if they
can't transfer the patient they call
Department of Health and say I can't
find a facility for this patient and
Department of Health finds the facility
for the patient they don't have the
right to object that is the rule and
that is the regulation and then they
have to comply with it and the
regulation is basic common sense if you
can't provide adequate care you can't
have the patient in your facility and
that's your basic fiduciary obligation I
would say ethical obligation and it's
also your legal obligation if you can't
provide adequate care the person must be
transferred if you have kovat people
they have to be quarantined they have to
have separate staff that's the rule if
you can't do it we'll put them in a
facility that can do it
that's the rule now when the person gets
transferred then they lose a patient
they lose that revenue I understand but
the relationship is the contract is you
have this resident you get paid you must
provide adequate care if you can't that
patient has to be transferred to a
facility where they get adequate care
assisting with the transferring
applications to other homes if they
can't if they can't do it then what
about if they can't provide enough PPE
because as you said yesterday it's up to
those facilities to provide the PPE so
if the state assisting in any way is
giving them thousands and thousands of
pieces of PPE you're right it's their
primary responsibility but it's their
primary responsibility like it's a
hospital's primary responsibility and
hospitals ran into problems nursing
homes ran into problems this is a
national story right you turn on the
national news any given time and you'll
have people saying we can't get enough
PPE it's been an international problem
so we were sending we were getting PPE
from China remember and we were getting
PPE and we were distributing the PPE
also and how many pieces the governor on
the emergency basis for nursing homes
alone four hundred and seventeen
thousand surgical grade masks one
hundred and one thousand gowns
eighty-five thousand face shields
422,000
gloves five thousand gallons of
sanitizer so on that scale we have been
on an emergency basis making it to
available to those facilities who have
called and said we can't while managing
as well hospitals and other facilities
that have had a desperate need for this
in addition to the nursing homes this is
since the middle this is since about two
weeks ago rotating staff to different
facilities so they can cover different
shifts I have not heard that have you
gotten from do H from these I mean sorry
from these facilities to do H
specifically from
they can't comply this same transfer
patients yes have you heard about
getting those calls we haven't gotten
the calls like that not that I know but
we can track it and find out what about
assistance for the PPE of you got well
we've had assistance for P P and his Jim
just mentioned the amount of supplies
that have been delivered to the nursing
homes do you have a number on how many
nursing homes have called for that we
just office buildings and you know to do
something partial I mean maybe in the
more urban there's maybe Syracuse
Rochester have by zip code with your
people look I think it's a very good
question and I think that's part of when
we talk about these regional analyses
and regional decision-making I think
that's that's one of them we said we
have a matrix right so it's more
essential businesses that are lower risk
would be the top priority right to
matrix to variables how essential is
your business how much risk does your
business bring government workers are
essential I would argue as a government
worker and you can socially distance in
a government workplace so I think that
would be one of the prime candidates in
a regional reopening strategy once we
get there right on the regional you want
to look at what is the overall infection
rate like this data you want to look at
the hospitalization rate you don't get
anywhere on a reopening discussion until
you see that
that hospitalization rate flat or coming
down right those are the CDC guidelines
they talk about phase one phase two so
that hospitalization rate has to be
coming down the infection rate has to be
low then you can start the conversation
on reopening regionally and calibrating
let's take one more sir this
non-essential workers who are who are
home right now are still being paid so
those workers are still being paid while
they're home right you have to look at
the numbers you tell me when the numbers
change I'll tell you when you want to
look at a flat or dropping
hospitalization rate in a region that
can reopen as a region we don't have the
kind of hospitalization rate numbers by
region that I can sit here and say the
North Country has been going down at
this rate but you need that kind of
analysis region by region
well CDC guidelines have a two-week
period 14 days I mean just to me let me
just ask
in the Capital Region we are I am
located in the capital region but
lieutenant governor Kathy hull is from
western New York and she was there Bob
Duffy my former lieutenant governor's
you know great public servant he's in
the Rochester Finger Lakes area so we
had that advantage we had just a
tremendous asset there with Kathy local
and Bob Duffy so they're doing that and
I consider myself a an adequate Capital
District but just to give you context I
was on the phone with all the governor's
yesterday on a governor's call this is
across the country this problem across
the country just for everyone to put it
into context New York state since this
crisis has begun has paid out 2.2
billion dollars to over 1.1 million
people who have applied for unemployment
insurance to give you a reference point
California's done 975 million Texas 400
million Florida 143 million Pennsylvania
600 million so we have gone above and
beyond in terms of ramping up we today a
number will be released later today
another two hundred and seven thousand
people that applied for and were
accepted for unemployment insurance
that's the number that's gonna be
released later today so that brings us
up to 1.4 million New Yorkers who are
now going to be collecting unemployment
insurance the backlog that remains is a
majority PUA which is the pandemic
unemployment insurance those are the gig
workers contractors self-employed people
who can't work because their kids
schools are closed people who can't work
because they've come into contact with
someone who's kovat positive that came
out of the federal cares Act which was
passed on March 27th that's where the
majority of these complaints are coming
from and yes those people have been out
of work or hadn't been working since
before then but the federal law that was
passed that enabled them to collect
unemployment insurance didn't even go
into effect until March 27th the feds
then put guidance out that said you have
to apply for unemployment insurance get
rejected and then apply for pandemic
unemployment insurance which was a
complete disaster
sir we have now streamlined that process
in New York that was this past Monday we
rolled out the new form which you apply
one time and then we make the
determination which pot you go into so
now the majority of the backlog is from
that category of people and just to give
you further context California isn't
even rolling out their ability to apply
for PUA
until April 28th and Illinois not till
May 11th so I know that this is hard
it's terrible you've lost your job
you're struggling to pay the bills it's
hard enough without having to deal with
bureaucracy and red tape this is on a
scale this nation has never experienced
in New York by comparison is actually
doing a tremendous job and we just ask
people to remain patient we've now put
3,000 people on this issue and we're
gonna continue to pound the phones and
do the data input until it's all
complete and everyone has what they need
yeah I do support this just to put this
in context the we have done far more far
faster than I think any other state in
the country and the number of people who
have gotten assistance is mind-boggling
but none of that matters right for a
person is only one check that matters
and that's their check and I get that
and if they don't get their check it
doesn't matter that it was only March
27th etc and some states aren't even
starting this yet but people are anxious
and it's their check that that matters
to them again the good news is it's not
gonna cost you any money because you
will get the check I know you want it
today but you will get it and when you
get it it's the same dollar amount as if
you got it today I still want it today I
get it but there is this is an
impossible problem that they handed to
the states they just pass a law just
goes into a fair March 27th we have to
figure out who's eligible how its
administered and then get a check out
the door it's an impossibility it really
is an impossibility hire 3,000 people to
put together a system but it is an
impossibility
again the only good news is you're going
to get the check it's gonna be the same
dollar amount yes I know you want it
today but we're getting it to you faster
than probably any other state in the
United States of America which as a
governor I feel good about but from an
individual who didn't get the check
none of it matters you get the last
question because of your undying
patience well the state investigate why
we're seeing so many more deaths than
some nursing homes than others you know
over 20 about 20 that nursing homes of
over 30 fatality six nursing comes up
over 40 and you know one well New York
also provide a plan to provide free
childcare to all essential workers
across the state yes that is going to be
one of the criteria for the
investigation that the Department of
Health in the Attorney General our
undetected